[Music]
if the view is your favorite show you
might be a little slow
yes it's time for
our view on the view
very serious music
they love to play the race card because
logic for them is hard on monday's
episode the ladies tackled the written
house not guilty verdict and true to
their feckless form their reaction was
something to behold see for yourself see
for yourselfers i can't go and protest
now without worrying that some nutcase
is going to have a gun across the state
line and come and shoot me that's the
problem that he has opened pandora's box
with some crazies out there oh the only
crazies i see around here are those view
chicks am i right
a sexist would be a sexist would say
but i digress says the sexist they talk
less sense than me after stealing those
pills from cat's purse
or
peels
that's appeal
then there's whippy
even all the excuses in the world
does not change the fact
that three people got shot
two people were murdered to me it's
murder i'm sorry all right and to me
that's about as educated illegal opinion
as the written house prosecutor
explaining that you should take a
beating instead of defending yourself or
that the closer someone is to you with a
gun the less likely they'll use it
here's more sunday if he were black
would he be free now no he wouldn't be
alive now people now will think well
someone can legally
come to a protest and under the cover of
law kill me
if he were black he could run for
president and probably win
but there she goes again playing the
race card she's more predictable than
gas after a cheesy gordita supreme at
taco bell
for someone named sunny
she sure is cloudy
and we'll be right back
with a very special episode of punky
brewster
kennedy
yes what is it about the view it's so
interesting that it's called the view
because they only have one view yes they
see everything through they see through
everything through one filter which i
would i would call the the race filter
or the press presser versus a press
filter all of them see it through the
view yes so you talk about you know the
monoparty system in certain parts of
wisconsin in seattle portland oakland
san francisco i would i'd throw all of
california in there and that's the
problem is they have a view that's not
really truly challenged so they think
that everyone agrees with them and you
don't grow when you're an environment
like that and they've actually devolved
and i think joy behar has turned into
marge shot
you know she's like marianne from
brooklyn meets marge
and i thought joy reed was my least
favorite joy and i i watched that clip
of joy behar and i'm like she's a truly
awful unthoughtful person
and i think that every abc executive
must be drinking actively
i would if i were watching the view your
impersonation of joy behar reminded me
however of the chicken lady and freaks
or the chicken lady in female trouble
the egg lady
you know i'm talking about no why do i
do this nobody knows what you're talking
about not even you know what i i tell
you all the time it
it's just you and me yes
everyone else is asleep yes yes i
googled it and even the internet doesn't
know yeah exactly
his phone is so fast our movie club is
so lonely it's us too yes watching
things that cause people to leave but
not together yes we know we watch them
alone and then we watch our spouses
leave leave yes
immediately you watch the view
no i i can honestly say i do not i don't
i don't have to
what kills me is oh when she goes to
protest
she's used it like a pronoun like what
are you gonna do today i gotta go get
milk get a haircut and i gotta protest
and i gotta be home by six
and she
she leaves out the part and they kind of
talked about looters
one percent of the crowd was looting
and yes they burnt down a neighborhood
but it was just one percent fuzzy math
yeah
so if that one percent person shows up
my house with a lighter i'm not gonna go
well there's just this one guy here
please light away i'm gonna shoot to
some [ __ ] in my front yard
he was
acquitted
by a jury of his peers
period there's nothing you can hate it
you're going but it's
it doesn't matter because it's not part
of their view she's trying to say the
protesters were nice and they were doing
their thing and this monster crossed
state lines and
even if that's not factually true facts
mean nothing because it goes back to one
thing they're improving yeah i don't
know every one of them they just there's
no facts can't argue with them so they
just make it up yeah i don't believe her
right she's like no main concern you're
lying awake at night that you can't pro
go to all those protests you always go
to because you're too scared that now
you're going to be shot by a teen boy i
don't believe that that's true go to
walgreens to get your prescription and
cisco sweetheart see how that is yes
exactly yeah i i just i don't believe
either of those things are true first of
all i don't think she's a big protest
gal no no what would she be protesting i
don't know wild noise in her
neighborhood this chardonnay is not cold
enough it is 11 in the morning this
should be much colder like anybody who
looks at her wrong like it's not
certainly not like issues bigger than
her no well that's hard people who say
good morning yeah wrong good afternoon
not on her wants
she said that's like their mate she's so
worried okay but you're not little kids
taking candy off her gingerbread house
before she eats them oh
that that has got to be a memory
right
[Laughter]
she's the the lady in the gingerbread
house can i add something very quickly
that's how the prosecutor lost this case
is he looked at the jury and went there
were heroes in that crowd and all the
people in the jury are like
you're full of hot garbage like my car
dealership got burned to the ground you
know it's like my friend's dress shop
got looted they were not heroes those
are people who live there right they did
not want their city burned down the
first time or after the verdict and the
prosecutors sitting there telling them
how great they were that was what a
dingbat that was that was a huge mistake
jamie what are your thoughts thanks for
including me
[Laughter]
why were you feeling alone i feel great
i actually dated a protester once really
yeah it's it's really great because you
can always tell what's wrong because
it's written on their sign
um i think it's so ironic
i think it's so ironic
isn't it ironic that the show's called
the view and there's nothing to look at
while you're watching it
you know what i mean
and how weird is it that their names are
joy whoopy and sunny how fun does that
sound
it's not fun and well none of this is
fun and stop with the crossing state
lines
yes i flew into newark i crossed state
lines to get to the studio
it's not that big of a deal that's true
and they're okay with open borders am i
right right yeah am i right huh i like
to cut it you don't like it gut filled
when other people use your joke
burns don't it i was gonna see if he was
gonna say anything he looked at me like
this guy
it was pretty good if i had three months
to live i put the view on so it seemed
longer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right you jerk
up next andrew cuomo's former employer
says he better get a lawyer